you know the truth is it is a simulation
you know and we told you that before you
linked into the thing and we told you it
would wipe your memory
and that you would feel like you were
helpless in the sense that the thing you
are right now you don't know what
the power that you will so you you chose
that just you know and we said that in
this moment
we would do a thing where we alerted you
of the fact that you have been
you had intentionally decided to dive
into a simulation
making you limited very powerful your
thor
in the in the human world that you're in
right now you're actually thor you've
uh you're you're a powerful norse god
that has gotten sucked into a very
temporary
like magic spell that isn't even that
powerful compared to the powers in the
world you come from but right now you
have become convinced that you are
a limited identity
in the mortal realm which you requested
by the way
you said i want to be an insurance agent
real estate agent school teacher
psychologist
fireman cop i wanted to be a
pilot somebody was a flight attendant
someone who worked in a
museum teacher somebody who
was a historian a failed writer a fellow
comedian
you and and you became this temporary
thing but
the truth is you're a god and you're
confused joe welcome back
[Music]
listen to me all those people that are
organized
they come hang out with us give me a hug
you don't want to give them a hug relax
why just really
all those people are just people man
like a white supremacist there were loss
they imagine if you gave a white
supremacist
five m eo dmt and let them sit on a
couch
one of them brown suede couches
they'd take three big hits and then as
the first one as they're exhaling
[Music]
yeah and they get sucked
into the center of the universe and they
realize there is no center because there
is no
boundaries it's all connected you're in
a soup
you're in an infinite soup of ideas and
biology and thoughts and prayers and
love and hope and happiness and jealousy
and
anal sex and it's all together
with cartoons and pop music
and cheeseburgers
just a bunch of different experiences
all
[ __ ] stitched together and sometimes
you're saying there's a redemptive
possibility and then they then the
aliens land